hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book 1 of his work on duties Cicero
brings up a very interesting doctrine
from stoic ethics that presumably he is
getting from Penn 80s and that is what
we have come to call the doctrine of the
four characters this this shows up
primarily just as in a primary sense in
in Cicero and of course he's taking this
from other authors and and summarizing
it for us it would be nice if he'd gone
into greater detail about this here but
it's really quite an interesting passage
in book 1 on Duty's and this has a wide
application there may be other ways in
which this could be parsed out but this
is a way of distinguishing the things
that are really up to us or that are
coming from us and the things that are
coming to us in certain ways from
external sources or at least from
they've been implanted within us by
something other than ourselves now I
want to mention here that what we're
translating as character is in Latin
persona originally character it also in
Greek prosopon persona they mean the
same thing it's a mask that the actors
would wear when you see like the tragic
and comedic masks in the theatre and the
idea is that each mask represented a
certain kind of person right and so we
can talk about a person's character in
the sense of being say for example the
miser or being the angry person or being
the generous person but we can also talk
about character in many other ways and
this is really going to stretch it
now sister'll starts by talking about
two distinct types of character that we
human beings each of us gets as he says
from nature that is the the way the
world works assigns these to us the
first of these has
to do with a common character that all
of us share you could call it Universal
or general communis is is the actual
Latin that he's using there and and what
does this consistent it's our
rationality this is what distinguishes
us from all of the other animals
according to the Stoics and really most
of the other ancient philosophers right
and that was a doctrine that I think
still many people today
find find quite compelling so this is
something that all of us have in common
it doesn't mean that we all express it
to the same degree or in the same ways
but he says that it arises from the fact
of our being endowed with reason and
with that superiority which lifts us
above the other animals and then he says
this is what all morality and propriety
are derived from and from this depends
the rational method of ascertaining our
duty so this is a kind of common human
inheritance that we all possess and you
know we were somewhat subject to waiting
to maturity before we can use it
entirely but it is something that we all
can you can say count on to some degree
now it gets much more interesting when
we look at the second thing that comes
to us from nature and actually Cicero
spends quite a few pages talking about
examples of this giving us adages about
what we need to do and we'll come back
to them in a moment this is this is what
he says is assigned to individuals use
the word single this here right he
doesn't just say particulars he means
individuals individual human beings as
human beings this is a really
interesting doctrine each one of us is
given certain talents or temperaments or
propensity and we're not we're also not
given others so each of us has not only
this general human character but each of
us also has this individual human
character and Cicero expresses the idea
that it's important for us to get to
know
oh it and to not try to buck it he even
goes so far as to say that there are
some things that are appropriate for one
person but would not be appropriate for
another person because of that
individual character that they have now
that doesn't mean that there's there's
things that violate you know universal
rules but when we get down to the realm
of application and what we might even
call style you know when we get down to
the concrete there's a lot of things
that are appropriate to some of us but
don't make sense for others and it could
be good to look at a few of his examples
he talks about some of the things that
people are given to he says some people
are given physical endowments like speed
for the race strength for wrestling some
are you know good-looking so others
don't get that some are stately there's
there's diversities of character some
have very witty others not so some have
great intellectual gifts some can be
very serious and they live in us too
your life you know Socrates is an
example fascinating and when it witty
genial conversationalist he was what the
Greeks called Ireland in every counter
station pretending to need information
so the Socrates irony for example is
viewed as being something that that
pertained to his character that made
sense for him not that everybody else
should try to imitate that and do the
Socratic method in the Socratic way this
is a very interesting idea that Cicero
is is working with here the third
character he says is that which ends up
being imposed or assigned to us by
factors that are outside of our control
he talks about chance Casas how things
happen to to go he talks about the times
Tempest you know sometimes we talk about
a person having greatness in
hosed on them by being in the right
place at the right time or you might
save and being in the wrong place at the
right time right or being in in in the
right place at the wrong time we could
go on and on with this but the idea is
that there are all sorts of things that
the the conditions that we find
ourselves in may offer us impose upon us
take away from us and that becomes part
of who we are as well so you know the
fact that that we're living now in a
time that affords the very possibility
of doing this my standing in front of a
chalkboard with a flip cam and lighting
that I bought from Amazon and recording
this and shooting it out to you through
the interwebs or you know 50 years from
now whatever this happens to turn into
you know maybe Holograms of some sort
well that has to do with our time if
this were 40 years ago that would not
really be a possibility for me and there
wouldn't be any Gregory Sadler PhD
channel giving you over a thousand
videos on philosophy at this point and
hopefully many more to come right so
there's all sorts of things along these
lines Cicero himself great example he
was stuck in a time watching the decline
and breakup of his you know Roman
Republic he found himself having to take
sides in a civil war these are all the
sort of things that can be imposed upon
us and they become part of our character
the fourth is the most interesting of
all I think because this is where our
own personal responsibility enters in
here you know you don't get to choose
being a human being and you really don't
get to choose this kind of character
your temperament or talents or whatever
it is that you are endowed with and you
don't choose the times that you live in
but you do choose what you do with it
you do choose what you do with your
actions your words your thoughts the way
of
life that you select you may have a
propensity towards a certain type of
life but you can go against that or
realize that and so he talks about this
character this fourth type of character
that is actually assumed by our free
choice you do kyono stroll right you
Nick iam is the ability to choose
between alternatives he even uses the
word will I know sort of all on path pay
from our own choice from our own will
from our own decision commitment where
it is that we decide to place ourselves
what it is that we decide to make of
ourselves so whereas these others can be
from nature or from fortune in the in
the classic sense of Fortunato right
this is really from ourselves this is
where we make ourselves into what we're
going to be so you know to use us a
stoic example Cato you know who's Cicero
looks at is like that is the stoic guy
par excellence
he had common human rationality he
probably had some pretty strong
temperament steering him certain ways he
rose to the occasion provided but it was
through his free choice that he
maintained an exemplary stomach life and
fought Caesar under Pompey lost along
with Pompey and committed suicide
there's some things even that you know
Cicero uses this as an example
committing suicide could be okay for a
Cato but not good for somebody else now
I do want to come back to this notion of
the second type of a character that
comes to us from nature in part because
Cicero tells us a few important things
about it he says that there's
dissimilarities and similarities that
exist in nature and characters and he
tells us that these are not to be
criticized or condemned the you know
mini-maid Thomond the two
Ronde Orem right these are not to be
made into vices unless they happen to go
against this common human nature he
tells us further
everyone should resolutely hold fast to
his own peculiar gifts as long as their
peculiar only as long as they're you
know propria proper to that person and
not vicious in order that propriety can
be secured
we shouldn't oppose the universal laws
of human nature but we should he says
follow the bent of our own particular
nature we really he almost goes so far
as to say we have a duty to get to know
ourselves and who we are and what kind
of people were going to be now all of
these ideally harmonize with each other
I think in the case of many people we
find these things at odds with each
other
and that can be another very interesting
subject of inquiry one that that Cicero
doesn't really go into here but but is
certainly worth thinking about
you